First full,
the motion is will self.
And so will self is not going to be walking over to the podium while
this is being said about him. In case you've never had a will self.
He is a very tool, uh, walks in a very strange way.
He's also when he's not walking in a strange way and novelists the broadcaster,
a political commentator and a literary critic,
his most recent novels are not that I need to tell you,
cause you read them all umbrella, shock and phone.
And his memoir will was published in
November,
2019 and will holds the chair in contemporary thought at
Brunel university no less. And the clock will has started.
Men and women.
Let's not talk about ladies and gentlemen this evening.
The agile motion is there's not much great about Britain,
but it's a pretty coy way of alluding to what we're going to be discussing,
which is,
does great Britain as an entity have any psychic
purchase on this anymore.
Do we think in terms of great Britain, what's meant by great Britain?
Well,
we're obviously not going to sort of look into the etymology of the term and
tell you that after the Romans left Britain and some ancient
Britains went to Brittany,
they started alluding to the place from which they had come as groaned.
Brittany, we're not going to refer to that.
I think we all know from the front of our passports,
if we're subjects of the queen, that it says there, great Britain,
a union of great Britain and Northern Ireland.
So that draws our attention to the union of 1707 with
Scotland. I'm not really much concerned with Wales.
I like Christopher lobes, Clara Hugh,
when all else fails, try Wales.
So I'm not going to concentrate on that nor do I want to particularly get bogged
down in issues of,
of patriotism and nationalism and attitudes
towards belonging to the nation in part.
And Anthony was right about this.
We were all getting on famously in the green room, uh,
very, very cuddly and there a lot of snap chatting and stuff like that. And,
uh, it it's really out of respect for the opposing team who, uh, you know,
Syeda bossy, very distinguished politician and Kate Hoey, my own,
uh, former MP a little bit D more Pappy possibly.
Now she's the house of commons, but between them many,
many years of exemplary public service
service for what I presume they think of as,
as great Britain. And I don't wish to impugn that personally.
Uh, of course you might think that that, uh, Ms. Hoey,
who is often been a strong advocate of the right
to hunt Fox is somewhat strange in a,
in a labor MP is in a way hearkening back with her
championing of this pursuit to a sightly medieval conception of our
nation and its culture and malls, uh,
a slightly feudal conception, a conception that,
that the belongs, uh, as well with that idea. So,
so fond, uh, to which, uh, the medieval monarchs and,
and the Baron Ray was so fond of which is that might is right.
Might is right. And I think that that idea is bound up in,
in great Britain. The idea of might being right.
So it could be that Ms. Hoey is, is a poet, is,
is opposing this motion because of that, uh, because of the Fox hunting,
uh, and as for, uh,
for Baroness Wasi barrenness,
what's that about Baroness? Uh, you know,
I mean, does she go hunting or Hawking?
She got some sort of a state to she occasionally clip clop around it and look at
some peasants groveling in the mud and say, get on with it. You peasants.
Uh, because I would say that if you style yourself as a barrenness,
you probably also have a looking belief in the idea that might
is right.
So I don't want to impugn them or their reasons for supporting the motion.
I simply want to draw everybody's attention to what the focus is here.
Great Britain, great Britain stalled itself. Great.
When it was the Hagerman,
the most powerful nation in the world.
And like all hegemonic,
great Britain believed that its value system wasn't objective
system of morality it's mite was indeed
right. Okay.
Do we still live in that country?
Manifestly? We do not.
We do not just think for example of the longest
deployment, the British army has ever been engaged in.
I refer to the deployment in Afghanistan following nine 11 in
14 years in theater. I think I'm right on this.
The British army suffered 500 fatalities. Okay.
The British army suffered that many fatalities in five minutes
during the first four hours of the battle of the Somme,
the willingness of the British to sacrifice the young men.
And it was mostly young men, but some young men,
men as well upon the altar of being the Hagan Mon is
manifestly no longer the case.
And indeed to hear the public conversation about the losses of those 500
service people you'd think that you lived in a very, very small touchy, feely,
Scandinavian country, not in a hegemonic tool.
The other thing is I I've recently I've been working,
they would name check before on a trilogy of novels that focus on Britain's Wars
over the past century. And as part of that research,
I interviewed senior British army officers who told me that
they now regard themselves.
This is the command of the British army as an echelon of the
American army, a bit like the United States Marine Corps.
They have to be interoperable with the American forces and they cannot
deploy, uh, by themselves, not what you think of in a Hagerman.
I put it to you that the reason we're even debating this tonight is the
Britain has a kind of hecka Mon hangover that leads it to believe
it still has hegemonic attributes. All we,
as powerful as our status,
as one of the world's six biggest economies would really suggest what
does our economy consistent? What do we in fact take?
Well, we export some death metal.
That's true often to quite unpleasant regimes like Bahrain or
Israel. Cool, well done, Britain gray,
but the other thing we tend to do and make a great deal of money out
of is a kind of financial Ponzi scheme.
It's the city of London,
the equivalent in economic terms of taking money out of the cash point with your
own cash card and running around to the bank to put in your own account.
That's what we're engaged in. That's what makes Britain great.
Is that kind of economics? Oh yeah. And exporting things like, you know,
great famous British brands like Burberry and Baba, you know,
they're normally showcased in things like the queen, right?
The, the, a Netflix series,
which bears absolutely no relation to our Royal family
whatsoever.
I am indeed a concerned citizen of this country.
And as such, I am a foil list rather than a royalist.
I liked Claire Foy and the role of the queen notch better than I like
Olivia Coleman and much better than I liked the actual queen who has
Paul Shaw for her thickest friend of Peter file's son.
So not much there to look to in terms of
greatness and then there's culture.
To what extent is British culture still great. After all,
I hold a British passport, I'm a writer I operate in that culture.
It may surprise you to hear this from me,
who you may think of as a sort of touchy, feely lefty typee person.
But my way of thinking is one of the problems that British culture has is a
problem in a lot of Western cultures have, which is,
it tries to embrace multiculturalism,
but there's a contradiction in terms there a culture is a vector that
carries forward a set of values. In this case,
it would have to be carrying forward if we're to be still be this great Britain,
those hegemonic values that we had when the sun never set on our empire.
But on the other hand,
we want to acknowledge the values of all these other diverse minorities in our
culture. There's an inherent contradict contradiction there.
I would like this country to respect the rights of all minorities,
but I don't think that that necessarily involves it in having the kind of great
British culture that it used to have.
We can see therefore that Britain might not
be as great as it was.
I haven't spoken much about the thing that is happening on Friday.
I myself was a Brexit agnostic.
We will see what's happened, but the damage was done ages ago,
the flotilla of Britishness was hold below the water line.
The thing about the British was unlike other nations and national cultures.
They never believed in utopia, but they did believe in Ukrainia.
They believed in a time that never was a marrying England
one in which Kate could hunt foxes and Syeda could
style a self-awareness and everything was just cushty.
Thank you.
[Inaudible].